avec des poils de pauvres ici c'est un
peu spécial
si j'étais en trop qui ne peut pas vivre
dans le big four ou à cause du gros
gibier qui vivent dans les pays chauds
cause d'une ligne à petite terre puis
des résultats qui ne peut pas vivre dans
le pays tomber il se sent solidaire
ce pot et gaulle et c'est avec des
truffes rouge qu'on compte qu'on
appellera vie pourquoi on les appellera
dit parce qu'ils n'ont pas le goût de
tri
pourquoi lui beaucoup et le management
si jolie fille au couple boisedu pauvres
par surprise mais avec décision quand
même bon n'ai pas agi beaucourt et
l'enclume première 2010 ça fait d'être
iront aux mollets des formations
brothers deuxième idée
l'ouvrier ne doit pas toucher le poids
du bord le 10 mai et louis viat le poil
dans la main araki voici
voici comment vit un ami ou ville un
mini souris tient dans la main gauche
devienne il tient comme un droit crise
où il co abreuvant plus poids et
comparer les ou moi à chaque fois
qu'on comptait l'ouvrier a assez de
poids pour faire une bonne saison après
15 ou 20 ans il fabrique son bisou
pendant tout l'été on fait tomber le
pinceau dans un match crucial pendant
tout est dit on fait sécher le brizault
à à l'automne les portons et c'est
pourquoi vous le trouvez plus de persos
japonais du xviiie bien
finalement avec siouxsie on n'a jamais
été voir jack nicholson dans five easy
pieces verront le jour qu'on attendait
la séance snack du drugstore
il ya suzy qui regarde un mec et qui dit
jésus soit et même jésus quel mal je
vais bien je garde tout type y joue un
type acidifiant je sais pas si oui les
genres de niro dans taxi driver alors je
me tourne vers siouxsie calmement vous
souvenez de la scène avec paul newman
dans left hand and gone d'arthur penn
what you you really want a confié m
it is that he was you want you to hell
et moi j'ai été confiée et souzy a eu un
geste qu'elle a piqué à elizabeth taylor
rached a alors je me tourne vers de niro
calmement ont marre on nous ment mm
bronson fait souvent ça à ce moment là
de niro se lève et je m'aperçois que
c'est un faux maigre ce qui arrive
souvent l'examinateur quand il se lève
il change de catégorie et là c'était
plus du tout de niro mais jean athmane
dans french collection de john
frankenheimer le pic même rue pitt joue
pas richard dreyfuss please stop win my
legs prise drop in drop it une décote de
terre et pendant qu'ils postillonner je
me disais je connais cette scène mais
impossible de me souvenir du titre du
film et c'est seulement quand il a dit
je vais démolir tout de suite je me suis
souvenu que c'était la version française
de ram people un film de francis ford
coppola
un film de la warner en si bonne carte
produite soeur pas de patton ronald
colby script writer francis ford coppola
lui-même et dans ce film c'était jones
kahn qui disaient non pas je vais te
démolir mais un gain impressionnant avec
une musique géniale hagen abris publics
jésus mais ces fusils qui souvent va
voir les films deux fois
ok ok ok ok beaucoup de gens qui
voudront qu'a fait le mec revient vers
moi en roulant john wayne jean on se
prendrait il va pas me faire le coup
classique du mauvais feuilleton
américain de série b vous savez la
fameuse pochette et non pas faire ça
quand même
eh ben le garde pas du tout c'est ce
qu'il a fait il a pris le pot de
moutarde et lentement il ment à tartiner
lager plein d'humour il m'a fait le coup
des marx brothers dans itunes casablanca
la classe vraiment la grande classe et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que j'ai laissé
suzy partir avec lui
bye bye choisi ne s'appelait pas saisie
c'était jeanine
parlant de vacances on peut dire que
l'année dernière avec geneviève on n'a
pas passé des vacances idiote quoi on
peut dire qu'on a passé des vacances
culturelles
nous avons été au pays des qu'helmut et
là nous avons rencontré un artiste je
vais vous montrer
est ce un travail artisanal un simple
chapeau de mariage pour hommes faits à
la main je vous la beauté de la forme
le jeune marié se coiffe de ce chapeau
pour aller chercher sa promise
et ils sont d'une noblesse parce que
c'est un très beau peuple quel quel
dommage que j'ai été malade
oui j'étais même parce que je ne
supportais pas leur cuisine parce que ce
sont des gens qui mangent comme il y a
deux mille ans et ça fait quand même un
poids mais c'est un peuple musiciens
écoutez je vous faire entendre une
chanson de bercher que j'ai pu noter un
jour que je reposer près d'une source
parce que j'avais eu un phlegmon en
finissant du finances d'une longue
histoire je le raconte rapport voici
donc cette chanson de berger qui est un
document brut
je vous précise christian glissé en
tournée vous m'accompagner avec le qui
coulait regardez le quai couler un
travail artisanal et qui coule
un qui coulait des qui coula voici donc
cette chanson qui est un document brut
je le précise on y va c'est un chant
d'amour
les jeunes gens se chante ça de
montagnat montagne
évidemment dans une salle ça rend pas
très bien mais nous continuons à paris
christian il me semble que nous sommes
pas accorder tous les deux
hop hop hop
christian souvenez vous qu'il ya quand
même une gamme a6 ya une gamme genève à
la bague accusés avaient auparavant on
laisse tomber
alors oui j'oubliais j'ai oublié la fin
de la chanson
ah oui le berger n'a pas chanté cette
chanson jusqu'au bout parce que il s'est
endormi
mais avant de s'endormir il a chanté
encore quelques mesures que voici le
fasse à un au travail artisanal
le fap à 1 face à des familles
oui alors c'est pour chasser les mouches
parce que là bas vous avez des grosses
mouches bleues très tenace et si vous
avez mouche au coin de la bouche vous
pouvez pas l'enlever avec un petit geste
gracieux comme ça faut vraiment ri très
fort
le lendemain de ma maladie je suis sorti
je suis sorti sans le phare mouche ici
pas plus cléments ah oui parce que ça
c'est une chose qu'il faut noter c'est
que dans ce pays
tout prend des proportions et non ça n'a
plus rien à voir avec les dimensions de
la france si si vous avez des montagnes
si les montagnes et non et quand vous
avez afrique mobile le vêtement
électricien c'est comme les coups de
soleil avec geneviève on a eu des coups
de soleil
eh bien nous avons été brûlé au deuxième
degré et alors là on a été transporté de
toute urgence à l'hôpital à dos de
chameau et là à l'hôpital on a eu un
accueil d'une gentillesse mais c'était
urgent qui vous met pas savoir gris
siens dans cet hôpital un accueil
tellement hospitaliers et les traits de
gentillesse pour ne pas nous déranger
toute la nuit les infirmiers chantait
mais à mi voix et le matin vous aviez
l'équipe de jour qui arrivait
vaillamment et là toute la journée
joyeux par exemple infirmiers qui me
faisais mes piqûres toutes les deux
heures
c'était joyeux puis on les a bien connu
avec geneviève on les a méconnu parce
que on est resté à l'hôpital beaucoup
plus longtemps quand tu croyais pas ce
qu'ils ont découvert qu'on avait attrapé
des animaux attention des amis d'un
chameau des bestioles énorme comme ça et
tenez vous bien ce sont des amis qui ne
s'attaque jamais alors et souvent aux
touristes mais tout est beau là bas tout
est bon l'architecturé
je vous ai parlé du temps peu de rab la
région
vous m'avez bien lu temple de la gelée
de la fenêtre de l'ambulance qui m'a
mené aux grands brûlés mais tout est
bout leur écriture aux avis zone
écriture la lettre je vais vous montrer
j'ai un paquet de ordonnance que je vais
vous délivrer la officiant plus voir ça
c'est la fameuse photo que cherchait par
tous elle est formidable je vois que ça
vous intéresse regarder alors ça c'est
geneviève et moi à l'aéroport voyez sur
le brancard derrière la en arc de cercle
se sont tous les infirmiers qui se
marrent et ici c'est le dr bakhouche le
dr bakhouche un joyeux lurons poule va
savoir
mais c'est lui qui faisait pendant mon
opération côté
marc écoute pas par marc tu ses marques
que maintenant maman travaille dehors et
c'est papa qui va s'occuper beaucoup de
marques maintenant et tu vois marc par
exemple aujourd'hui
eh ben c'est papa qui va faire manger
marc tu veux alors papa c'est pas comme
maman parce que papa lui il va profiter
de ce repas pour apprendre plein de
choses à marcq
on va commencer à dire la marque
ça c'est une assiette et marque
il va manger de la purée avec du jambon
non pas son beau parce qu'en bon jambon
voilà on fait pas plus avec la même
c'est pas preuve m'a un petit garçon
propre ma mais ils mangent avec huillet
tiens voilà cuillère ma cuillère ne sert
pas balancer purée dans l'oeil de cette
ag idioma il maman et aurait donné une
correction mais papa c'est pas pareil
parce que papa lui il compte sur
intelligence de marc demarcq y mange
très bien avec lui hier c'est très bien
elle sera jalouse moment m on fait pas
des rues la bouche vers le pur et eva
cette apathie moment qu'il fallait
manger pour fermer bush père mais voilà
il ya une autre chose marque il faut pas
essayer d'avaler tranches de jambon
entière comme tu le fais parce que
estomac de marque c'est un petit sac
alors élastique mais petit quand même ça
fasse un pas oui mais ne recrache pas
n'engage pas non wouah du lait pour
faire passer non mais lecavalier dans la
bouche tant pis et tongres au pont petit
sa mama mama tu va pas pleurer pas
pleurer surtout la bouche ouverte
non c'est pas beau à voir alors tiens
prends de la mi-mai pour cacher tout ça
les cache cache c'est plus propre nom
ma non tu vas pas toucher à éternuer m'a
pas été relu imap et pas crié papa
aurore décrit ma marraine ou papa il va
balancer pur il faut jeter dans la
gueule de matar est ou du mahb enflé
mouflette un mot d'argot que marche ne
comprend pas ne peut pas s'en fout
écoute chérie c'est pas de ma faute
sans kolnik a commenté
j'espère que vous avez tous compris
cette leçon de français et que vous avez
tous maintenant que le présent de
l'indicatif c'est ce qui se passe en ce
moment
exemple mohamed vient qu'au cours du
soir pour apprendre le français
mohamed pouvez vous nous raconter une
histoire au présent de l'indicatif quoi
monsieur je peux raconter des histoires
j me promène dans la rue il y en a une
voiture qui roule
les oiseaux chantent c'est plein temps
il y en a des jeunes filles jolies deux
jolies il y en a qui relancent dans un
bar moi jveux l'anthologie ya le patron
qui dit non qu'ils n'ont pas faim
négative oui c'est très négatif qu'ils
en pensent comment moi j'ai dit moi je
dis pourquoi je lampe en forme
interrogative qui appelle une réponse
non tucci tu l'appelles des flics
mohamed mohamed je vous en prie soignez
votre discours pourra consister en dix
mois
les flics en lui qui sont morts dans les
jolis costumes en avec les rues et
boulevards et les bâtons qui brille
supplement
il dit tu t'ennuies papier et j'ai dit
je n'ai pas le mobile
j'oubliais le moins pire maison mois
mais la langue française est une langue
subtil qui vous permet de vous exprimer
avec nuance vous pouviez dire j'ai
oublié mes papiers à mon logis mais je
me fais fort de vous apporter dans les
plus brefs délais j'ai pas le temps de
parler comme ça tout de suite il en est
tout petit dans le cube bon dans la
camionnette roulant chez mohamed ouahmed
dans le véhicule vous pouviez vous
exprimer correctement alors tout joli
dit ferme ta gueule préparatifs du
deuxième président d'honneur jean collet
mohamed
je vous en prie revenez au présent
présent présent ils disent on va te
faire une grosse tête tu auras une sale
gueule qui ont chuté ou non la salle
gagnes tu l'a tout de suite mais moi j
que washington a tout le temps passe et
5 passes et composé par intérieur aci
futur à ses tweets en moi mais je vous
en prie oublier le passé je peux pas
oublier passé je me regarde dans une
glace
on vient de passer
prenez exemple sur racine notre grand
racing qui savait si bien s'exprimer au
présent écoutez je ne trouve qu'en vous
je ne sais quelle grâce qui me charme
toujours et jamais ne me lasse à vous je
les trouve qu'on vaut je ne sais quelle
grâce qu'elle met charme toujours et
jamais ne me lasse je trouve quand vous
je ne sais quelle phrase qu'elle me
charme toujours jamais le mot là tu le
trouves comment
m
mm tulle a réussi ton petit numéro toi
mais qu'est ce que j'ai c'est pour avoir
un fils pareil tu la réussite la
provocation nominaux t'as vu ta tenue du
der garde et la glace et a vu ta tenues
costumes sur mesure cravate assortie
lunettes écaille made in england et
attaché-case à 23 ans quand je pense que
ta mère et moi on a le même blue jeans
depuis mai 68 était pas gêné il n'est
pas gêné leur entrée dans la chambre
dans cette tenue pendant que je suis en
train de fumer un petit joint avec mes
copains automnaux tu te sens pas déplacé
avec ton est de sortir du salon du
prêt-à-porter au milieu de mes copains
qui plane et ta chambre
sa chambre alors parlons-en sachant
explique moi c'est une chambre d'hôte
hotu désinfecte ou quoi j'avais
tellement avant que mes copains arrive
que c'est moi qui inscrit des slogans et
des graffitis sur les murs demi donc
c'est à moi de faire c'est à moi de le
faire parce que des limites à la provoc
quand je pense que devant mes copains tu
étais de vanter d'avoir fait son service
militaire devant gérard qui pour se
faire réformer avaler une fourchette qui
étant compensées
et moi oui moi moi moi ton père qui me
suis fait un lavement avec une solution
javellisée 12 boîtes de maxi temps et
c'est à nous que tu viens parler de ton
adjudant à qui tu as envoyé thème on
veut en fait je comprends pas je
comprends pas tu connais quand même
notre passé à ta mère est à - tu connais
notre passé anarcho mao écolo autonome
et tu comprends pas notre monde ne te
voir cadre avec un plan épargne logement
assuré et pourtant et pourtant on a tout
fait pour toi si si si on a fait tout ce
que des parents pouvaient faire pour
leur enfant dans sa poussette tu as
assisté à toutes les grandes manifs les
gaz lacrymo on est et en oxygène et plus
tard et il vient en lozère nourris au
fromage de chèvre tafer le larzac seront
pratiquement pas je n'en avais tu
valentin de ta mère tu vas d'entendre ta
mère quand elle va revenir de son voyage
en inde avec sa petite amie très
longtemps quand elle va apprendre que tu
veux te marier parce que monsieur veut
se marier nos valeurs alors explique moi
ça existe encore cette histoire le
mariage mais sais tu que ta mère et moi
on a toujours vécu tous les deux
librement ensemble et avec celle que tu
as toujours appelé tati
tu vas entendre ta mère elle qui a été
membre du service d'ordre du hamelech
pendant dix ans quand elle va lire sur
la vitre arrière de sa voiture
cette littérature pour dupont lajoie
avis à toutes filles qui rentrera dans
cette voiture le sourire aux lèvres
qu'elle ressortira la culotte à la main
bravo 3 monde
non mais tu veux que je te dise non non
mais tu veux que je te dise je suis
tellement écoeuré que moi maintenant je
démissionne alors il faut plus rien me
demander maintenant ses rideaux terminé
fini d'accord bien dit bruno tu es
demandé à pendant que j'y pense t'as pas
cent balles